Now let's go through each one of them.
Writing "potato" may be fun, but it does not involve any sort of if-then-else processing,
so it won't show off our defect.
The expected answer is that the web page shows potato,
and the answer we'll get is the web page shows potato.
So this is not a good test case.
Over here, if x is less than y write "tomato", else write "eggplant".
We need a little more in this test case like values of x and y,
but this is the right idea.
Let's say that x is something like 0 and y is something like 1.
We then expect it to print out "tomato" but because we've made this bug over here,
it will print out "eggplant" instead.
So the observed behavior will differ from our intuition
or from our specification of what should really happen,
so then we know there's a mistake.
Over here return 2 + 3.
Again there's no conditional control flow, so this is not a very good test for us.
Finally, over here factorial does involve an if
in determining whether or not the program terminates.
This is a very good test because almost immediately, factorial of 5,
we're going to see, oh, is 5 equal to 0?
It's not. Bug. We'll return 1.
We won't actually make any recursive calls.
We'll get the wrong answer really fast.
So this is a good test case for us.